Well, like I said, we started with the Lord's Supper
to tangibly remind us of the gospel
and our response to that act of God
is then a whole life response.
Remember, that's what Romans 12 one says, we looked
to this last week, I appeal to you
therefore, by the mercies of God
to present your bodies as a living sacrifice, holy
and acceptable to God, which is your spiritual worship.
And worship is not just singing, worship is response life.
Here is all of me for all of you.
That's what we're gonna follow up on today.
That idea of true worship, where we're gonna learn
a more holistic and full response to God's grace
as we study how Hannah responded
to God's grace in her life.
And so we're gonna see that in First Samuel chapter two.
So take your copy of God's word
and turn there with me again.
We're continuing our series called He Shall Reign.
And we're looking all the way through the book
of First Samuel where this is showing us
how God is the king over all things
and reminding us of that.
But we first need to remember Hannah's story from last week.
She was the first character really that we saw in this book.
Remember Hannah's story
because Israel out of slavery in Egypt,
now they had settled in land.
God had graciously given them, But as they settled,
they began to slide morally
and spiritually things did not go well.
As they landed
and as they drifted away from God, they drifted closer
to self dependence, idolatry,
false religions, Which led then to instability,
poverty and near constant battles
with other nations around them.
The the Philistines were constantly picking on 'em and
and that was because of the nation drifting away from God.
And Hannah was a miniature of Israel.
She was barren physically.
She could not have children biologically
yet she was also constantly face to face
with Elena's other wife
who was way more fruitful than she was.
And so there was this battle she was facing daily.
Well, instead of pouting, she prayed.
What we saw was that she prayed with trust and faith
and humility that God would give her a son
to take away her shame.
That's what she asked God for.
But as she did that, we saw a shift in her life
that she prayed with this trust and faith.
But she, something changed in her heart to where she shifted
and became so satisfied
and God himself that she was able, willing to give away
that child to him, to let that child serve
for life in the tabernacle.
And she dedicated that son that God had given her Samuel,
she dedicated him to the Lord's service for life
and left him there to serve.
Well, what we're gonna see today is her response as she did
that, what the Bible records, as her response
as she left her son, her three year-old
or so son in the tabernacle.
The one she asked for the cherished one,
she left him at the temple to serve the Lord.
What was her response? How did she respond to the Lord?
Well that's the first 11 verses
that God's word records here in first.
First Samuel chapter two.
As God provided as God met her in the middle of all of this,
what did she respond with
as she saw God meet the needs she had far
beyond having a son?
Well how did she respond?
Look at verse one down through the first part of verse 11,
one Samuel two and Hannah prayed
and said, my heart exalts in the Lord.
My horn is exalted in the Lord.
My mouth rides my enemies
because I rejoice in your salvation.
There is none holy like the Lord.
For there is none besides you.
There is no rock like our God.
Talk no more. So very proudly,
let not arrogance come from your mouth.
For the Lord is a God of knowledge.
And by him actions are weighed.
The bows or the like, the arrows cross bows
of the mighty are broken.
But the feeble bind on strength, those
who were full have hired themselves out for bread.
But those who were hungry have ceased to hunger.
The baron has born seven,
but she who has many children is for loin.
The Lord kills and brings to life.
He brings down to shield the place of the dead
and raises up the Lord.
Makes poor, makes rich, he brings low, he exalts.
He raises up the poor from the dust he lifts the needy from
the ash heap and make them sit with princes
and inherit a seed of honor for the pillars
of the earth are the lords.
And on them he has set the world.
He will guard the feet of his faithful ones.
But the wicked shall be cut off in darkness for not
by might shall a man prevail.
The adversaries of the Lord shall be broken
to pieces against them.
He will thunder in heaven.
The Lord will judge the ends of the earth.
He will give strength to his king
and exalt the horn of his anointed.
Then Elna went home to Rama God,
we need you today to see what you want
to show us from this passage that you give us clarity,
give us insight, give us your spiritual eyes to see
what you want us to see.
Challenge us, convict us, encourage us
that you may be glorified.
That's what we want, God, more than anything, that we
glorify you and you change us in response.
Help us. In Jesus' name we pray. Amen.
So we're looking at Hannah's responsive worship here
and what we see is a model for really all believers,
how we are to worship the Lord as we pray, as we respond
to his grace in our lives.
What do we do? How do we do that?
That's a great example here.
And first what we learned is
that Hannah's response was focused on the Lord.
That's the first part of this that we understand.
Hannah's response was focused on the Lord.
She was focused on God.
And you saw where her mind was as she prayed this
as she may be even saying this, right?
It was all on God 24 times.
She refers to God either he or God
or a name with nine of those being the name Yahweh.
Like when you're reading your Bible
and you see the word Lord in small capital letters,
it's referring to the name Yahweh,
which was God's covenant name.
He gave to Moses the great I am
self existent one.
This is the name he had specifically
between him and his people.
This was the idea of Hannah's heart being solely focused
on the gracious God.
The one near to her soul over and over and over.
All she says is God does this. God does this.
'cause it's not just the names, right?
She doesn't just say God. She says the names. Yes.
But it was what he does. He weighs actions in judgment.
He shatters the strength of the wicked. He humbles people.
He provides for the barren in the land.
This is what God does.
He's in charge of life, both death and resurrection.
He is in charge of whether someone's poor or rich.
He's in charge of raising people, lowering people.
He also protects his people.
He destroys his people, his enemies like all of it.
This is who she's talking to. This is her God.
She can't get this out of her head.
This is theologically astute,
powerful language from a un uneducated woman.
That's why all of that, that's why Hannah prayed verse two,
there is none holy like Yahweh
for there is none besides you.
There is no rock like our God.
What that means is that he is exclusive. He stands alone.
There are no competitors to his throne.
Listen, this is not like some good
and evil battle thing that we often put in movies, right?
This is not something that is like, man,
we hope God wins out in the end 'cause he's strong.
We hope he's strong. We don't really know.
That's not what this is talking about.
There is none
besides the Lord God Almighty, right?
It's not just that God's like the best option
out of many options.
There's no one else, there is no other God.
He is the only one.
And there's no other, no other rock,
no other foundation on which we can build our lives.
See, again, Hannah is a, a microcosm of Israel.
And so we've been seeing that Israel's been searching
for all kinds of other foundations here
and there for life, for stability,
for security, for prosperity.
They're looking for it all over the place.
What can I build my life on?
And what it had gotten them was destruction and pain
And sorrow.
So what Israel been trying and now they see the results.
Maybe that's where Hannah was before chapter one.
Maybe she, she was longing for the foundation of a son
to take the shame away,
To Secure her future.
Maybe that's where she was.
She was longing for that foundation that
that was gonna fulfill it.
But now at this point, she knew
that only God was gonna be the one who was secure enough,
the rock that she could build her life on the only
true eternal foundation.
It wasn't anything else. It wasn't even a sun
which was secure her future, socially.
It was nothing other than
God.
Maybe that's where you are today,
like we were confronted with last week.
Maybe, maybe you are searching
for fulfillment in all kinds of other ways
That This life can
Offer us.
Like are you building your life on the foundation
Of success And the
foundation of pleasure?
Maybe it's of of some kind of athletic ability
that you're building your fam your,
your foundation of your life on.
Or maybe it's family image
and you gotta make sure everybody's doing the right things
or the way it looks to everybody else.
Maybe that's what your foundation is
or maybe it's your talent or whatever else.
Listen to what Jesus said about
that Matthew seven.
He said this verses 24 through 27 students,
you might remember this one from camp, remember, uh,
16 inches of rain and 16 hours and it was flooding
and everything was going crazy.
This is what God led us to.
That next morning Jesus said this, everyone then
who hears these words of mine
and does them will be like a wise man
who built his house on the rock and the rain fell
and the floods came and the winds blew
and beat on that house, but it did not fall.
Why? Because it had been founded on the rock.
But he doesn't stop there. Listen to this.
And everyone who hears these words of mine
and does not do them will be like a foolish man
who built his house on the sand and the rain fell
and the floods came and the winds blew
and beat against that house and it fell
and great was the fall of it.
The same storm is coming for each one of us.
Now that's the storms of life, of course, right?
Just normal everyday storms that come to all of us.
But this is also primarily talking about the storm
of God's judgment at the end.
And, and the question is, where is your foundation?
Where are you building your life today and forever?
There is no rock like our God.
Hannah said, you know why
there's no rock like our God?
Because she says there is none holy like the Lord,
meaning he is set apart, he is unique.
He's the only one. There is no other rock.
It's all sand eternally.
And even today there's no rock like our God.
Hannah understood that.
That's why verse one, she says,
her heart exalted in the Lord.
There was a joy, there was an excitement in him
because of what she now knew was true.
Listen, some of the deepest times of worship come from
whenever we're met in our deepest times of need
by the Lord, right?
It's not just that you come in here feeling all good
and everything's right and all this is perfectly fine
and then I'm worshiping.
No, it's like in the deepest darkest time of need.
That's where God meets us. That's where the worship comes.
Hannah experienced that she felt
and knew his goodness to her in her deepest time of need.
In the midst of maybe not even getting the answer,
she had the joy in him.
Same for us today.
Isn't it true worship,
A joy-filled response to the grace and mercy of God.
True worship means our whole lives
are focused on the Lord.
We just say God, all of me, I It's you've done every, all
of me like as we work, not just in this room, right?
As we work, as we parent, as we play, as we sing,
of course in all of it, we are looking to him
and we're doing it for His glory.
That's why this song was written called The Doxology.
We're gonna sing it together. So
I'm not singing a solo, right?
We're gonna sing this together, but listen to it.
Praise God from whom all
blessings flow.
Praise him.
All preachers here below.
Praise him above the
heavenly hall.
Praise Father, son
and holy sing the amen.
Amen. Hannah was focused on the Lord
to praise him with all that she is
because from him all blessings flow.
But in so doing with that perspective,
she was also humbled before her Lord.
Like she was focused on him, but also humbled before him.
Her response was a humble spirit
before this God that she's focused on
like so much of what she prayed here was an acknowledgement
that God is God
and she's not, that
he does whatever he wants.
So she's humble before him.
There is nothing that she can do compared to him.
Like verse two says, there's none holy like the Lord.
Verse three says, we should be humble before this judge.
Verse four talks about God shattering the strength of those
who claim to be mighty.
It talks a lot about raising and lowering, right?
Flipping these things on its head.
Even the end of verse eight, Hannah, pray this.
For the pillars of the earth are the Lords
and on them he has set the world.
Like just reading that, it reminded me of job's story
like you know, job who questioned God at times
over all the bad things that were happening to him,
which I would too.
I mean honestly, you read the story,
it's like wow, that was hard.
But listen to how God responded to Job.
Whenever he questioned God about what was happening to him,
listen to God's response.
Job 38, where were you? This is God talking.
Where were you when I laid the foundation of the earth?
Tell me if you have understanding
who determined its measurements, surely you know,
or who stretched the line upon it on
what were its bases sunk who laid its cornerstone
like and God goes on like that for two whole chapters.
And then he gets to this. This is Job 40.
Verse two, shall a fault finder contend with the Almighty.
He who argues with God let him answer it.
I read this from Trevon Wax said, if there is a God
and he really did make you
and the rest of the world, then you don't get
to define him in relation to you.
He gets to define you in relation to him.
We don't understand it all, but we try to make him.
We pull him down and fit into our system.
Or we could just say, no, no, no. He defines us.
He is in control. That was Hannah's perspective, right?
Like think about the way she would've originally
designed her life to be was to have a bunch of babies
to be fruitful and multiply, to have standing in society.
That would've been what she would've done.
That's security, right?
She would've designed her life that way,
but God had a different plan for her life.
He had a better plan for her life,
but it demanded her humility
before him to be able to be a part of it.
She had to say, okay, God, I don't understand
how this is working out, but I'm gonna trust you,
humble before you.
It's not my plan, but I'm going to trust your plan.
Israel was similar. Israel had been walking in proud
arrogance against Yahweh.
They'd been doing it their own way,
living lick wicked lives thinking that by might
and strength they're gonna overcome it
and they can figure it out and make it happen.
What they needed to remember was that it was God
who delivered them from Egypt to begin with.
It was God who provided for them in the desert.
It was God who brought them into their land.
It was God who reigned over them in the land.
It was all God.
And they needed to be humble before him
because what he was doing was setting new
pillars in society.
They had to recognize that
and say, no, no, God, you're the king and this is your plan.
This is how you're going to do it.
Uh, maybe that's something we all need to be reminded
of today that that we
are not really as in control as we think we are.
Like we talk a big game. We, we think we have control.
We think we're strong.
But what we need to be instead
is humble before the Lord.
We need to be humble before the one who judges, the one who
lifts up the weak, the one who ordains life
and death, the one who cuts off the wicked, the one
who destroys his enemies.
We need to be humble before him.
We play God so often and he's like, no, no, I'm God.
You're not. And so be humble before him. He is all of that.
But not only that, think about the gospel
and be humbled before him.
I, I've, I've said this before, I believe it.
Christians should be the most humble people on the planet.
There should be no pride, no arrogance.
We should run away from it.
We should be the most humble people on the planet.
Not just because Jesus was and
because he commanded it of his followers.
This is what, because this whole thing is not
based on our abilities.
Like the only thing we bring
to the table is our sin, our failure.
Like that's what we're offering in this deal here.
Like well, we've got our sin and our
and we're gonna plop it on the table like we got something
to be proud of in this.
We just bring our mess, we bring our failure.
It is God who justifies. It is God who redeems.
Our salvation is only through the perfect life.
Jesus lived that we could not live his substitutionary death
in our place for our sin,
his victorious resurrection over sin and over death.
We could never do it ourselves.
That's what he brings to the table.
We bring our junk that he paid for.
See why we should be humble.
Like I love how Ephesians two
says it for by grace.
Remember grace is a gift for
by grace you have been saved through faith.
And this is not your own doing.
It is the gift of God.
You don't earn a gift,
not a result of works so that no one may boast.
The only thing we boast about is our weakness.
We we boast in Christ.
That's what two Corinthians 12 says,
like boast about my weakness.
I bring nothing to the table except my failure.
And that is good news because then he paid it all for me.
He did it all for him. We boast in Christ.
He did it all for us, which then should lead us to worship,
which is what verse one says, my heart exalts in the Lord.
I rejoice in your salvation. That's why.
Because she realizes she brought nothing to the table.
This was all God doing.
She was barren. She couldn't produce a baby.
In fact, God had to
miraculously give a baby.
Is that not the same way we have barrenness in our lives.
We have a mess. We cannot produce anything spiritually.
God has to do it for us.
So, so are you excited about the gospel?
Like are you stunned?
Am I excited over the grace of God of what he's done for me?
Am I living then a whole life response
because of all that he's done where Hannah says,
you gave me this child.
I'm giving it back to you. God, you gave me everything.
You gave me salvation, you gave me every talent,
every ability I have, every resource, every history I have.
You've given it all to me. So I'm giving it all back to you.
Is that how we respond to him?
Hannah was humbled
before the Lord as she responded
to his goodness in her life.
She said, okay, God, I'm all yours.
That's what we need to be as well.
Yet there's also something else about her response here.
She wasn't just humbled, she wasn't just focused.
She was expectant of the Lord
in her prayer, in her worship.
She was expectant of the Lord.
Remember, things were not great in Israel.
Idolatry, abuse, selfishness that was
rampant as they drifted away from the Lord.
But look at the language. Hannah sings here.
She'd seen God's goodness in her life.
Look at what she prays.
Verse three, God knows even all that's hidden
and he's gonna judge accordingly.
What that means is the wicked aren't gonna get away with it.
Like she's looking at Eli and his sons over here.
We'll see this next week. All the priests were wicked.
She's like, God, you gotta do something with that.
And I know you will. Verse four,
not only does God humble those who think they're strong,
it says the feeble bind on strength.
What it means is that God strengthens the weak.
Like he, he fits onto the weak
strength like armor.
Verse five talks about how God will provide
for the hungry flip on its head.
The social status structure based on being barren
or fruitful like that won't matter anymore
because it's about what God does.
And then just look at the upheaval in society.
God's work does here. Look at verses seven and eight.
The Lord makes poor, makes rich, he brings low, he exalts.
He raises up the poor from the dust he lifts the needy from
the as sheep to make them sit with princes
and inherit a seat of honor.
Right? That's an expectation. God's gonna work right?
And he's gonna come through for the week.
He's gonna make sure that everything is
taken care of as it should be.
Even more judgment. Verses nine
and 10, God protects his people.
He shatters those who stand opposed to him.
See, just like Israel should have been alert to,
Hannah was looking around at all the desecration
of society and instead of getting depressed about it,
she was actually hopeful about it.
'cause she knew that God is the Lord Almighty.
He is the holy one. He is the judge.
He'll make all things right.
He'll bring things back into order as it should be.
She knew that's who God was.
And we'll see specifically the end of verse 10.
Look at the back half of verse 10 says, the Lord
will judge the ends of the earth.
He will give strength to his king
and exalt the horn of his anointed.
Now let's wait a second here.
'cause they don't have a king yet.
No one has been anointed yet. Samuel's still a baby.
He's going to be the one to anoint the king,
but they don't have one yet.
So what's she talking about?
Well, I believe this is a prophecy
that has a dual fulfillment.
There's a future king coming that will be all
that she just prayed right here.
Because here's what's
interesting about this prayer from Hannah.
It's not the only time we see it, it in scripture.
It's not exactly repeated in other
places, but it's very similar.
And anytime you see something repeated in scripture,
that means it's important.
So when you see the same themes over
and over again, you're like, whoa, I need
to zero in on that.
And one of those times
that is actually almost repeated is at the very end
of Second Samuel, a book end to one was once,
one book, by the way, first
and second Samuel, we've split it up.
It was actually one to begin with.
They were combined together.
And so this was the beginning of first Samuel to us.
But at the very end of second Samuel, second Samuel,
chapter 22, king David at this time, he prays a lot
of what Hannah just prayed.
I want you to read the whole thing later.
Go to Second Samuel 22 later today. Read all of it.
It's powerful. But look at, just listen to verses 22, uh,
chapter 22 verses two and three.
This is David's prayer.
He said, the Lord is my rock and my fortress
and my deliverer, my God, my rock in whom I take refuge
my shield, the horn of my salvation, my stronghold,
my refuge, my savior, you save me from violence.
That's already familiar.
And then you see throughout his prayer things
like God thundering.
We saw that before. Rescuing his people,
shattering his enemies.
His way is perfect. He's a refuge for his people.
Then this down in verse 32, for who is God but the Lord
and who is a rock except our God.
Now that sounds familiar, doesn't it?
That's exactly what Hannah just prayed.
Then think about this, the very last verse.
Great salvation he brings to his king
and shows steadfast love to his anointed, to David
and his offspring forever.
That's what Hannah saw as she looked ahead in her prayer,
right strength to his king, to his anointed.
She, she saw it before it happened.
David experienced Israel's greatest king.
He experienced this anointing. He was saved.
He was strengthened by the Lord God almighty. He knew it.
This is the bookend of one and two Samuel.
But he gets even better because about a thousand years later
there was another impossible pregnancy.
There was another bringing of a baby to the temple
to dedicate it to the Lord.
There was another calling of a baby
to be be something great
and involves Mary the Virgin mother of Jesus,
who prayed a very similar prayer to
what Hannah prayed.
'cause Mary had to believe God's plan
and this is how she prayed in response as she believed it.
Luke one Mary said, my soul magnifies the Lord.
My spirit rejoices in God, my savior,
for he has looked on the humble estate of his servant.
From behold, from now on,
all generations will call me blessed.
For he who is mighty has done great things for me.
Holy is his name.
His mercy is for those
who fear him from generation to generation.
He's shown strength with his arm.
He has scattered the proud in the thoughts of their hearts.
He's brought down the mighty from their thrones,
exalted those of humble estate.
He's filled the hungry with good things.
The rich, he sent away empty.
He's helped his servant Israel.
In remembrance of his mercies, he spoke to our fathers,
to Abraham in his offspring forever,
almost exact you tie that then with
zechariah's prophecy at nearly exactly the same time
where Zechariah about John the Baptist
was talking about Jesus.
That Jesus was sent to raise up a horn of salvation
through David.
Like all this links together, doesn't it?
But we can see then is what Hannah prayed
in chapter two of one Samuel.
What she prayed in light of God's redemption
and his grace, what she prayed could only be fulfilled
by Messiah,
by God the king himself.
God would do it in certain ways,
but Hannah could not look
for fulfillment in anything tangible here in this earth.
It was only in God.
Israel itself could not look for safety and stability
and prosperity in a false God or even in an earthly king.
It was only in God.
We today, we cannot imagine that a leader
or a political party
or a government of any sort will provide
what our souls deeply long for.
It's only found in God.
It only comes in God alone. How do we get that?
How do we find that? It comes as we focus our hearts
and our lives on him
and his kingdom that surpasses all others.
It comes as we humble ourselves before the King of kings
and the Lord of Lords it.
It comes as we worship expectantly
that all that we long for all the things that we want
and know that justice needs to bring all those things
that it is coming in him, not in anything else,
that he is the solid rock that we can build our lives on.
That's what we find in God alone.